hi my name is Nina I'm gonna show you
how to make guacamole or the ingredients
that you need for God chromoly of course
avocado you can use regular Tomatoes i'm
going to use cherry tomato because it's
easy to eat and I'm going to use
cilantro and green onion and just
regular red onion you don't need a lot
just a little bit and then um garlic I
like guacamole because it's yummy and
you can eat it with crackers or tortilla
chips last time I made if I make one for
Evan I made a hobo huge bowl put it
right in front of his face he finished a
hobo in five minutes I didn't even get
to a taste okay so we start so now I'm
gonna chop cut the onions and two small
like dice and then it's tough to cut and
make you cry the reason why I put onion
in the guacamole because onion let you
keep the grass family fresh it will last
longer okay this is all chopped up
cutting the ball now I'm good
the cilantros first we have to watch the
cilantros it has a lot of like sand and
because a mud in the cilantro okay here
you go you can rip off the stems I
really like the smell of cilantro and I
could just need it like this cut it
really small fine you don't have to put
this much but because we really like the
salon chose so we're going to add a lot
more okay I'm gonna chop it up like this
okay this is done chop chop so now I'm
going to cut the the cherry tomatoes of
course having washed cherry tomatoes
first okay so it just rings the tomatoes
you don't have to put too much tomatoes
in there because it makes the the
guacamole watery I like it I love it
think you could try to cut the cheese
tomatoes really small
okay then put it in here next one I'm
going to use maybe two of the green
onions I always flip the stands off
instead of used to cut but it's up to
you and then the bottom part usually is
dry and brown I'll just tear it off I
cut in half because it's faster to cut
then chop it really small can mix it
together now we're going to cut the
avocado
f
use a knife step on it and then wake a
little bit and then put it out and now
I'm gonna scoop up the avocado with a
spoon
oh the small bowl for a lotta avocados
okay now you just have to mix it well
mix it well just push it down after you
push it down you cannot start to taste
and then also at the squeeze the lemon
juice oh I forgot the garlic too it's a
long day um crye-leike I smarties
teaspoon too much teaspoon ok so make
sure everything is mixed well the
cilantro is two in the bottom so I'm
going to sue scoop the scoop it up
so we could add the salt earlier but I
like it after I like everything is mixed
well first then then add this salt okay
the cistern and I'm going to have lemon
squeeze the lemon juice first I will
press down the lemon so later on when I
cut it off it will be easier to switch
the the juice out okay cut in squeeze it
out okay half half of laminates good
enough unless you like it really sour
but you don't want it too much otherwise
will be too watery also lemon will keep
your guacamole longer to same as an int
okay so you wanna taste it triscuit
brown rice really
alright this is all going tonight thank
you for watching the video if you like
them if you like this video please like
the video and leave a comment and
subscribe bye okay okay oh stop it you
gotta leave in 10 minutes wait a matter
oh my god don't forget to click here to
subscribe to my newsletter to get
actionable inspiring motivational
believe advice every single week to your
inbox hi I'm Jason j-rod fonseka of Ra's
online com and i want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring XD only newsletter i
prioritize and look forward to period